I'm speaking to 41-year-old Fumiyoshi Shimizu...
...who has personally experienced how overwork can severely affect mental health.
Fourteen years ago, Shimizu-san was one of the 800,000 workers...
...employed at convenience store chains across Japan.
Because of punishing schedules and general labor shortages across Japan,...
...24-hour stores are difficult to staff.
Shimizu-san's dedication to his job reminds me of a pervasive Japanese phrase,...
..."ganbaru" or "to persevere through hardship."
But persevering on just three hours of sleep a day...
...puts the body and the brain under enormous stress.
A year into the job, Shimizu-san was diagnosed with depression,...
...but he ignored his doctor's advice to take a break.
For better or for worse, there's a deeply ingrained mentality in Japanese society...
...that the group comes before the needs of the individual.
Because Shimizu-san was put on unpaid leave,...
...he asked the company to compensate him for his overtime hours.
Shimizu-san took the company to court and won.
Shimizu-san was awarded 15,000 US dollars in compensation for his overtime hours...
...and for the damage the work had done to his health,...
...a rare outcome in Japan.